hi everyone this is a new partner at YC
today we have max Rhodes founder and CEO
of fair fair went through why since
winter 17 batch and YC continuity also
led fair CDC run very excited to have
you here max excited to be here so we
have a lot of questions from our Twitter
audience but I think we're gonna touch
on three topics broad topics today one
is the early days of fair and two will
talk about scaling and third we'll talk
about fundraising and how you choose
partners so we'd like to start with the
first one which is the early days of
fair you know it's not often we see
companies trying to disrupt retail and
local retail especially given the
strength of Amazon so can you talk a
little bit about how did you come up
with the idea of fair and what were some
of the early days like which gave you
conviction that there was something here
to build I went against the advice of
almost everybody I knew and left square
about three years ago specifically to
start a company and I export a bunch of
different ideas and did everyone tell
you not to leave squit everyone told me
not to leave without like a burning need
to start a company like don't start a
company just to start a company and I
actually think in retrospect they were
probably right and we got kind of lucky
but I I just plowed ahead and we
explored three or four different ideas
in the process and it was actually
around the third idea that we were
exploring we were we were trying to sell
dental drills from Brazil hmm how did
that happen you can square to dental
just from Brazil one of my co-founders
had a connection in Brazil to this
dental drill manufacturer and it was
like diamond coated and it didn't it was
supposedly didn't cause pain and it was
quiet and this was actually the moment
or I realized this is why people tell
you not to just go leave to start a
company because you and you can end up
trapped with an idea that you're not
really that
sited about but you feel this pressure
to do it because it's what you set out
to do we actually started to try to
raise money with it and it got bogged
down in the legal questions of can we
actually extract the IP from Brazil and
I remember being on the phone with
Marcelo my now CTO after one of these
hour-long discussions where we were
racking up crazy
legal bills and just saying like what
are we doing why are we trying to sell
dental drills this is not what we should
be doing we we know how to build
software that's what we did it square
you know we built Square Capital we
built cash app you know this is what we
know how to do and so we made the very
difficult decision to for our third idea
to just scrap it and start from scratch
again and I decided to work on what
ultimately became fair and the reason
why we picked this idea was I had this
experience of introducing this product
called the blunt umbrella to the US
market it's a signed umbrella from New
Zealand and I knew firsthand how painful
the wholesale market was how hard it was
to get products in two stores in the
whole time that I was doing black cuz I
did it was on a site at square I kept
going to these trade shows and kept
thinking like there really should be a
better way to do this I wasn't sure if
local retail had a future
you mentioned the whole Amazon thing and
to be honest
ie that was kind of where my hang-up was
and and so I started did I just decided
I know this problem exists like maybe
it's a small market but let's just start
somewhere and I started to dig into the
data and lo and behold local retail
actually is is making this comeback
which now is starting to get a little
bit more attention now but at the time
it was just sort of stitching together
census data local bookstores have been
coming back since 2011 since borders
went bankrupt pharmacies are coming back
grocery stores are coming back
seeing this Renaissance of shop local in
communities all across the United States
and so that's we started to build
confidence that like okay maybe there is
something here maybe we maybe there is a
wave that we can ride here if we can
figure out how to crack the actual
problem itself which is the the
wholesale problem and so I started doing
customer interviews and it was in the
customer interviews that we uncovered I
think a pretty interesting insight which
is if you ask a local retailer if you
ask like a small shop owner what's your
favorite part of your job they'll say
finding new products yeah that's what
gets them out of bed in the morning
connecting with makers bringing new
products into their stores and that's
what excites their customers - it's that
moment of somebody walks in and sees
something oh this is so cool where did
you get it and that delight that they
see and their customers that's what it's
all about for them and then if you ask
them well how many of the products that
you carry are new mm-hm and most of the
time it'll be somewhere between 20 and
30% and that was where I started again
of why and the the answer always was
because it's scary to bring on new
products if you're a local retailer and
you're buying new products that you've
never carried before you don't know if
it's gonna sell there's you don't have a
relationship with a vendor so they're
not gonna give you terms so you're gonna
be shelling out your cash which is a
very precious resource for a small
business and if it doesn't sell your
stock and so your one bad buying season
away from going out of business and so
they have a portfolio approach where you
know they mostly stick with what they
know is gonna work and then occasionally
spice it up with a few new things even
the new products actually generate a lot
of sales yeah exactly when when they get
it right when they get it I get it right
yeah it's it's very important to get it
right
I realized why nobody had ever figured
out how to move this market online it's
because they're going to trade shows to
solve inventory risks so like get over
that fee
so that they can touch and feel the
products and really feel good that this
is something that's gonna do well in my
store and that ultimately led to us
thinking well how can we how can we fix
this how can we help them fix the rim
into a risk and that's where we really
drew upon the square experience where we
started thinking you know what has
changed mm-hmm and the one of the big
things that change that has changed is
that all of this data about SMBs about
their inventory about their social media
presence about who their customers are
on both sides of the market both makers
and retailers that's now available
online
yeah really for the first time ever it's
changed five years it's only in the five
years yeah I did it what prompted it to
happen on inside SMB started adopting
social media so they started really
relying on Instagram yeah that's true
Facebook and then they started adopting
cloud-based point-of-sale systems Square
Shopify before before Square most
point-of-sale systems were on-premise
systems and so the data lived on a
server inside the store if they even
used a point of sales yeah and a lot of
times it's just like paper and pen with
a cash register so it was this
confluence of social media ecommerce
presence as well was a new thing with
Shopify so is this big wave and we a
little bit made the bet based on our
experience from square that we could
take on the inventory risk for these
stores and eventually build machine
learning algorithms that would predict
what would sell where and actually get
better at managing inventory risk for
the store looking across thousands of
stores than what you could do you know
if you're an individual store owner
yeah and it's actually fascinating
because of YC we often say especially
that early in the batch
it's about far under market fit so it's
about solving your own problems that you
had from your experience having launched
blunt umbrellas and the unique
experiences you all shared from square
to Riaan
and the SMB market now you know some of
the things you described is part of the
unique insight which was like people
like to touch and feel people want to
manage inventory risk you know still
exist even if you move online so can you
explain what is fair what does it do and
how does it help solve some of those
yeah of course good question if you
don't have that context it's important
so fair it's a wholesale marketplace we
connect small retailers one to ten
location stores on the kind of stores
that you'd find on mainstream all across
the United States that are coming back
and then we have makers craft brands
smaller manufacturers on the other side
kind of the the maker revolution types
of folks and we connect them together
with this wholesale marketplace so
rather than going to trade shows or
hiring sales reps and doing this all
face-to-face or over you know with pen
and paper they move their whole business
online and you know it it works just
it's like a wholesale version of Amazon
and the the key insight or the the key
differentiator for us is actually
something that's been used in consumer
ecommerce for decades to move consumers
online it's free returns so we're just
replicating that playbook that's been
used before but that's how they do the
touch and feel because you give them
free returns and a set duration yeah
exactly and and I think the free returns
matters more in our business even than
it does in the consumer business because
of that inventory risk yeah oh sorry
that I was referring to earlier it's
also harder to manage so free returns
really would not have been possible even
five years ago I think but with all of
this data were able to predict what
sells where and and that's how we're
actually able to so the better matching
will help you also solving that it does
a show yeah but then you offer a turn so
that they still have the touch and feel
that's right that's right
so it's sort of it's it's a value
proposition that both draws the the
retailers in and then it also actually
makes the system smarter and it it then
turns into another value proposition
which is we are seeing what's selling
what's being returned and we can then
use that data to help retailers make
smarter buying decisions so if you come
in and you place an order and you return
part of it we then know the types of
products that don't do well for you and
we'll recommend you other products that
are more likely to do well yeah and so
what is your vision for fair what do you
think happens to local retail five years
from now or 10 years from now given what
you are trying to do yeah I think that I
think that local retail has some big
advantages over particularly big-box
retail but even over Amazon and the
reason for that is these retailers have
spent the past 50 years figuring out how
to compete with larger competitors that
have larger assortments lower prices and
the ones that survive were the ones who
evolved and figured out how to offer
more curated assortments better
experiences a lot of the things that
people are now talking about is the
future of offline shopping that's what
local retail has been doing for the past
20 years and that's why they're doing
well at the same time they've evolved
the industry around them has not because
basically the technology energy is
basically ignored this whole space sort
of assuming Amazon's coming it's gonna
go away like I did two years ago when I
was kind of hesitant to move into it and
so what I believe we're going to do is
we're going to accelerate the shop local
movement by basically eliminating a lot
of the advantages that big-box
competitors have traditionally had over
retailers so if you're a big-box
retailer one of the ways that you made
life hard for small retailers is you had
more data so you had your assortments
much more optimized there was less cost
in your supply chain so you could offer
lower prices you were able to get
capital so you had larger assortments
and these were things that smaller
retailers never had you also actually
had returns big-box retailers have had
free returns for decades okay it's
called buybacks yes
and so we're leveling the playing field
for these small retailers and so you
have the the tandem advantage of you
know the
seismic shift in consumer sentiment
towards shopping local
and then the leveling the playing field
with technology and I think the future
of retail is going to be local local if
you look back over thousands of years
trade and retail was about community
yeah like trade is what brought us
together in the first place it was you
know I I would trade some pots to
somebody who was you know maybe a great
blacksmith and that was the economy it
was local yeah it was about community
and I think over the course of the past
hundred years we lost that a little bit
and I think that you know people are
craving a return to that and I think we
can help you use technology to support
that revival of community in that
revival of local shop yeah no I agree I
think the shop local moment is real and
also like access to unique supply is
real and you're also seeing a lot of
makers individual makers trying to
establish themselves in that regard so I
think that movement is definitely
happening let me take two now let's
think about your one for fair right so a
lot of fun you know quite a few founders
have a really good vision and a clarity
of thought but when it comes to
execution you still have to go through
the ups and downs of the motion so talk
about the first year at fair you know
right from when you went through I see
demo day and post Emily when did you
really start thinking you have some
early signs of product market fit you
clearly had found a market fit yeah
but how when did you really actually see
that yeah I would say it came in waves
there were definitely early signals you
know customers they would lean forward
in customer interviews and then I
remember our first order
I brought a printed sheet of paper with
just the names of the products and the
prices and I said if I let you buy this
on consignment where there's no
inventory risk do you want it and the
retailer said yes I want all of it so
that's how you made your first sale yeah
yeah that was not on a website no not on
this vision that you have laid out for
fair okay so you took a printout yeah
and when and which store was this a wink
okay now in Noe Valley okay okay yeah
and that was the way we got most of our
first pride ten customers
came that way as we started to try to
scale the business we definitely started
to have doubts because it just it was
feeling too hard like I could just
through sheer force of will sit somebody
down and get them to buy the products
but once we tried the sales it was yeah
it became hot it became a different
and once we hire a couple more
salespeople yeah you know it just every
time we added a little bit more friction
to the process the the excitement and
the the conversion rate and everything
just started to deteriorate so yeah it's
dr. slowdown did it manifest into slower
growth or was it you've got an idle bit
but it wasn't accelerating and it just
it we could feel it it didn't it didn't
quite feel like this is it the way that
the inflection point may you hit a
scales laughs exactly
and so we played around with a bunch of
different value props we we did away
with the the net 60 payment terms or the
net 90 payment terms we started trying
discounts and I remember at one point we
were at a trade show and I was I
literally was trying to give the
products away mm-hm
and it turns out trade shows are a
terrible venue for us because the
customers tend to be a little more
old-school and they just didn't want it
they didn't want to buy online and well
they're trying to see other products
available that's right they're there to
touch into feel they're not there to
order on a computer we went to the the
New York and out trade show which was
actually where I originally got the idea
launching blunt umbrellas I'm it was
there that we were trying all these
these dumb value propositions just
throwing stuff against awhile trying to
sell a dollar for 90 cents and I called
Danielle a one of my co-founders and I
said it's not working I think we should
go back to the try before you buy
you know inventory risk thing because
all these other things aren't working
and he said yes let's do it I think
you're right and so that gave you more
conviction yeah yeah that we were on the
same page that he also felt like
something was off and we went in that
morning to the tradeshow booth and 9:00
a.m. retailers started showing up and I
started pitching try before you buy and
they started seeing the products that we
had literally in one day today yeah we
sort of wandered in the wilderness for a
few months trying different value
propositions and honestly like not
maintaining our conviction while Olivia
was building up the assortment and it
turned out the reason that we were
struggling was we just didn't have
enough supply we didn't have the right
supply the value proposition was amazing
but it without the supply it didn't
matter and when you combined the two
together on that morning it was magic
like and how much did the girl change
after that oh it was overnight overnight
yeah and you you could again you could
see it in their faces
people were spending hours shopping on
the site and buying and placing big
orders and I called Danielle and I said
this is it yeah yeah and we were invited
been all hand-to-hand combat sales and
we decided this is it let's open it up
let's launch and so it took us about two
weeks to rebuild the website and pull it
out of invite-only we turn it on we have
a website from printouts yeah exactly
advanced a little bit from there and I
was funny enough on my honeymoon the
week that we launched it always happens
it always happens that yeah yeah you're
always on your honeymoon
yeah and and I remember like sort of
sneakily checking the metrics in from
the Galapagos and it was just green just
all green every day 10% 15% 20% 30% and
we went from doing $100,000 in sales in
August to a million in our
tober oh wow just in the span of three
months not even three - yeah yeah that's
pretty that's really good and you know I
think many companies in YC we've seen
who have actually found really strong
product market fit like go through one
of those defining moments and if I
remember four instigate it was actually
switching from search for a tomato to
search by a store Wow it was literally
people because people buy groceries by
looking at a store right they don't if
you're buying shampoo you know whether
you want Pantene or something else but
your groceries you know whether you go
to Trader Joe's or Whole Foods or
Safeway and so switching to buy store
church like dramatically changed yeah
the bike is its little things and I I
remember asking Mike Moritz at Sequoia
event who obviously he yeah amazing
investor and has seen a lot I think was
on the board of Instagram yes he's still
on the board yeah yeah and I asked him
like what sets apart the great companies
from you know those that don't do as
well and he he thought about it for a
minute and then he said constant
application of force mmm they have a
vision and they just keep pushing
against it and I think that's a great
that's part on because I think one of
the founders you know last week hip told
us this which is from the outside it
feels like we were genius in figuring
out how the strategy but only the inside
we know we tried a hundred things and
the one thing that worked yeah we didn't
know what's going to work that's right
so I think like that's a great way to
like you know move from the early day
story to scaling people management yeah
because clearly now you have very strong
product market fit and you are how many
people do you have right now a little
over 100 a little over a hundred okay so
the second phase of company building is
really about scaling people management
right and especially scaling yourself as
a CEO what has been your biggest
learnings so far as you've scaled as a
CEO one or two things that you'd love to
share with the other founders so you
it's been an interesting experience for
me because I
came from a product management
background I had just a tiny bit of
people management experience at the tail
end of my time it's how many people did
you manage its square my last team I
think I had seven or eight okay but that
was four maybe six months prior to that
it was just all product teams and when
you're a product manager you you're not
managing people you're managing through
influence and you're managing through
you know just convincing people
desperately to try to do what yeah
nothing to do yeah and so it it took me
some time to figure out what was
different about people management and it
I think one of the things that I really
struggled with was I didn't know what
kind of relationship I was supposed to
have with the people who worked for me
can you elaborate on that yeah as a
product manager it's all about building
really strong relationships and building
trust and building you know credibility
to get people to listen to you and as a
as a founder CEO especially people will
listen to you mm-hmm
no matter what yeah pat up to a certain
point obviously but then Authority
sometimes to a fault
yeah I'm devoted about bringing it up
with you yeah yeah yeah and I didn't
know how to negotiate that and it felt
uncomfortable at times and I think the
thing that I really struggled with was
is it okay to build relationships with
the people that work for you
you mean relationships outside of work
like friendly relations yeah and just
like I kinda I think I put up this wall
I had a couple early experiences where
we had to let a few people go and that
was really really hard and I think that
led me to feel uncomfortable building a
relationship because if I have a
relationship that I'm not going to feel
comfortable giving direct feedback or
potentially having to make a really hard
decision if I have to and I ended up
hiring
an executive coach Shefali at the
recommendation of one of our board
members Kirsten green who walked into
our office at our first board meeting
and pulled me aside afterwards and she
said I think you can come here ship
coach because I think everyone's
terrified of you and I love Kristin
she's amazing
yes this is amazing um yeah
and so I hired a leadership coach and I
worked with her and I read a book called
radical candor mm-hmm and I think that
was really transformational for me
because radical candor basically the
whole premise is you have to build
relationships with the people that that
work for you because you need that trust
because without that trust they're not
going to feel comfortable speaking up
they're not going to feel comfortable
being held accountable for results I
think the the word for it is obnoxiously
aggressive when you give feedback and
you don't have a relationship you're
being obnoxious ly aggressive and it
really it's it is a person in a
defensive place if you give feedback
when you have that relationship there's
trust they know that you have their best
interests at heart they're going to take
it well and they're gonna implement it
feedback as a gift for you Isaac you got
a bet it's delibird well it's taken well
yeah in the stronger that your
relationship is with the person the
easier it is to give that feedback and
so that was really that made a big
difference for me I calmed down a lot
mm-hm talk about that when you say calm
down a lot you know I often think like
it's really hard to be a founder I know
we talked about this briefly before this
started which is you know this one part
of the day certain thing goes well and
this another part that if something
doesn't go well so like what is what's
the secret behind coming down like how
do you calm down
so there are some tactical things that I
do I meditate
we every morning at 8 a.m. I lead a
meditation for 10 minutes using
headspace with you know anywhere from 5
to 15 20 people at the company that I
found helps a lot because it just makes
you more
aware of your own state of mind so part
of it is just is just developing that
awareness of being mindful of your own
state of mind because I was so stressed
out that that first year and a half and
that was also part of what created that
wall is like I didn't even feel like we
could talk about anything other than
work because if we weren't thinking
about work then we might fail yeah I
remember when the did the CDC around and
I think you had taken a two-week
vacation someone on your team message
just saying where you know I think we
had to exchange Docs and someone said
max is finally taking yeah yeah yeah it
was I
it was my honeymoon which was five days
and I was checking metrics more than I
should have and that was basically it
yeah for that first year and a half and
yeah there was just that feeling of that
I so many I'm sure every founder is
familiar with that like existential
dread that you carry around and that is
a weight that that weighs on the whole
company I mean it weighs especially on
the people that that report to you and
it I think it hinders performance I
think that it it really it people can't
do their best work when they're under
that much arrest and then honestly part
of it was we kind of got through the
woods yeah do you fund strong the
product market yeah and we figure out
the business model and it became less
about survival and it became more about
how big can we make that this which is a
lot more fun and a lot less stressful so
part of it was circumstantial yeah and
then part of it was just sort of coming
to terms with if it fails so what yeah
yeah no like letting go of that that
fear of you know if it fail so what I'll
pick myself back up
and I'll try it again yeah because it's
I can't imagine doing anything else I
really really love this job and so if I
have to do it again I'll do it again and
that that also I think
was was helpful yeah I mean I think Jack
and his advice to Sarah and note that he
proposed on Twitter did say it's okay to
fail public yeah so let's talk about
people because that's clearly the next
element of scaling right one you figure
out strong product market fit you have a
very good business model and a vision
that can really you know if the company
is able to realize its full potential
can be a huge opportunity in an enabling
more liek local retail but it comes down
to the team at the end of the day right
and you're scaling from 20 to 72 now
about 100 and probably in a year another
100 so who where your first 10 hires our
first hire her name is Katie she was
she's our founding designer she was
there from the very beginning I knew
that design was going to be really
important for us I knew our customers
were designers I I knew from square that
design is so important in small business
because small business owners act just
like consumers they make decisions
emotionally if it's not easy yeah
they're done and so I knew that we
needed to build a great experience
I knew it needed to be beautiful I knew
we wanted to create a strong brand
because I'd seen that work at square
yeah I know you guys have a very high
bar for design because our office looks
so beautiful it looks like a local
realtor Katie yes yeah that's Katie so
one of your first key hires were
designed yeah design was design was
probably the the FIR really really or
not and outside of engineering who are
any of the other key hires you made in
Newhall
so another really important hire was
this woman Olivia um she came from Bain
and company management consulting firm
and she sat me down in the first
interview and she said this is how your
business works mmm and she did she was
right it was like spot-on she understood
it all the the very and it's a
compliment yeah business to really get
all of it and she managed the assortment
so she started out managing the
assortment yeah and she did a phenomenal
job with that and and really we with
that
you were missing that that was without
her figuring that out I don't know what
happens yeah because we just did not
know what our retailers wanted because
that wasn't we knew small business I
knew the problem from the wholesaler
perspective but I didn't I didn't shop
enough yeah in in local stores that was
like one of the key missing ingredients
that is an important point right because
all three co-founders I don't know how
much of experience you had shopping
local retail any visits someone earlier
I really needed somebody who had that
and and she brought that once we're
starting to scale and we were live she
took over Facebook advertising and she'd
never done Facebook advertising before
and we tried to use a contractor and it
was a mess and it wasn't working and she
just took it over and like a week later
we were you know doubling our growth
rates through Facebook advertising and
at that moment I was still product
manager and CEO and it wasn't working
and Daniele and Marcello were telling me
you're you were doing a terrible job as
a product manager we need a higher
product manager I didn't want to hire an
experienced product manager because I
just I think in early-stage startups
it's it's really hard to find a strong
outside p.m. and so I decided let's
let's give Olivia a shot and she became
our first p.m. no fantastic yeah yeah
when you get the right tire they
actually scale really well yeah and
honestly she's now better than I ever
was which is a really really cool thing
that's awesome let's talk about so
that's the first 10 hires which is
really important in the early days of
the company and you know every company
has this unique story so clearly in your
case it was both the design as well as
the assortment plus your p.m. you know
which Olivia brought which was key right
actually like something Dec startups
when I asked them I think put in stripe
and Rex case the CFO and the GC were
part of their first entire so you know
depending on the company in space you're
and it's important that yeah they are
part of the first end hires but let's
switch gears a little bit to xx yeah
right because that's the second hardest
thing that a company really struggles
with who is the first outside executive
that you hired and talk a little bit
about the interview process and how long
it took you
get them I read somewhere that an
executive the way you define an
executive is somebody who consistently
Wow's you with insights and results and
doesn't need to be managed yes pretty
good yeah yeah I usually say if you have
a booking executive team the CEO can go
on vacation for a month and not much a
little bit you know not not know much
negative impact I think that's I think
that's right yeah and maybe when you
come back actually you're it's like
crazy yeah but the first person we hired
outside who came in and was just
immediately that was this woman Shan who
who we actually tried to hire in January
of 2017 and she turned us down
she and I were in the same class at Bain
she was she ran customer support at
topango in content at topango we we
interviewed her I mean I knew her well
and we put her through a pretty rigorous
interview process where she came in and
met with four or five people on the team
we had her spend the day on-site doing a
bunch of exercises with us and sort of
digging into the work because I knew her
as a friend and I did and then we did
pretty thorough reference checks I
talked to four or five people that
worked with her at tapingo and all of
them said you know she is a they said
she's just a force of positivity and
enthusiasm mm-hmm she's phenomenal with
process and and that and she knows how
to run a customer support team we missed
her the first time around she turned us
down and I kept checking in texting her
meeting with her I met with friends of
friends to try to like get her talking
yeah yeah it was a little creepy but
that's not what I've heard a lot of CEOs
do that yeah yeah it's I do think
somebody said that the best CEOs never
lose candidate yeah well they lose but
they you know like you that's the big
keep trying yes the
you just don't lose a candidate and that
stuck with me and that was the approach
that request and I knew Shan I knew Shan
was the person for this role we Customer
Support was gonna be so important for us
especially he started yeah yeah yeah I
knew we needed her we needed somebody
who was warmer and and could really be a
positive force of energy and more calm
and more calm
hey I'm not exactly calm but okay got it
but but she's warm and she's just you
meet her she just fills the room up with
with warmth and somebody who could scale
customer support and she came in and we
were we were in a tough spot by the time
she joined on the customer support side
you know turnaround times were out of
control we were hearing all over the
place from everyone that people were
complaining about our MPs score was
going down and within like a month we
had 12 customer supporters and they were
all amazing we went from three to twelve
and in a month in a month maybe maybe
two yeah and how did the NPS change and
immediately NPS stabilized customer
satisfaction score shot up and while
while she was scaling up we unlocked
this growth channel that where we went
from doing she joined in June and we
were doing like 1.5 million or maybe one
or maybe two million and in sales of
money in sales a month and three months
later we were doing seven yeah and
normally through those periods of growth
like I saw it this happened to coinbase
having a little bit at square where you
just customer support oh yeah and for us
it actually got better yeah our metrics
improved through that period and that
was in in then after that she took on
our warehouse yeah where we deal with
returns like just I can keep throwing
more and more out at her yeah she's
about to go on maternity leave for four
months which will be an interesting
experience as long as the process of
sorry she said okay already for sure I
actually think it's gonna be fine yeah
because she's hired really well
underneath her which is
another definition another thing that
executives and I haven't had to worry
about customer support or anything that
she's focused on at all yeah since she
joined great so uh you know we talked
about early days Kaling people want to
switch topics a little bit to
fundraising you know in the evolution of
a company at different points in time
company does need capital to scale for
growth how did you think about
fundraising and what did do you look for
a partner each time you approached
fundraising well from the very beginning
we knew that this was going to be a
business where capital was going to be a
weapon because of the the payment terms
and the consignment model we started
thinking about fundraising pretty early
we raised before we even had a product
we raised a little bit of capital with
the idea that the business model was
gonna require that and then we raised
again after YC and the you raise just
see these they pretty quickly I mean we
were eight so yeah so we did we did our
proceed or whatever you want to call it
these yeah it was like 500k yeah I don't
know what it is in December of right
before we started working on it
full-time in December of 2016 and then
we raised our seed in March of 2017
right after YC and we raised from
Sequoia Khosla and a little bit from
Kirsten 4runner and then six months
later right after that inflection point
where we went from a hundred to two
million we raised our RA from coastland
and Kirsten stepped up in in coal ad I
find fundraising to be a pretty big
distraction like I like making the
process quick and short and just getting
back to work I mean if we can create a
really quick competitive process
I'll trade maybe a little bit of of
upside on the margin to be able to run
the process quick and find a partner
that we built a relationship with that
we feel really good about and so that's
what we did with the B we knew capital
especially heading into the
holidays was going to be important we
didn't want to get stuck in a place
where we were throttling growth it felt
like and it continues to be the case
that the opportunity in front of us was
even bigger than we realized and so we
really wanted to build up a war chest
and and take advantage of the
opportunity ahead of us
and so we ended up raising you know in
the span of about three months about a
hundred million dollars but what advice
would he give a founder if they came to
you and said really you've had goods
great success with fund raising what
would be like the one or two like
tactical or pieces of feedback or advice
you'd give a founder momentum is really
important take advantage of momentum in
the business and raise when you've got a
lot of momentum I also think one other
thing you guys had where it was actually
the clarity of thought and vision on how
to build a big business and what it is
many years out yeah not just the sale
versus next year which I think a lot of
funders actually don't spend as much
time and so you can get caught up even
in growth runs about metrics which is
very important but that's about
performance to date and the question
about potential really relies on how
articulate you are yeah having a big
vision and that's something that I
learned from Jack at square Jack was
always thinking just huge about what
Square could be even it was just a
little card reader he was talking about
how we were gonna change the world and
that's something that we we've tried to
do which I think and that's just what I
that's what gets me out of bed in the
morning but I think it also helps with
fundraising because that's what gets
investors excited the other thing I will
say is Jordan not all money is created
equal
yeah and we've been really careful about
bringing on partners that where there's
trust where I feel like they can really
help us in some meaningful way where I
like spending time around them that's
like you're gonna end up spending quite
a bit of time around your investors so
you want to feel good about that and in
then I do think that the brand name
matters that was something Tony from
doordash told me early on was it sounds
like it sounds like a a kind of a I
don't know like an annoying thing to
optimize for but it really does make a
big why do you think it matters
supportive man in big brand name
investors it matters with recruiting
yeah by the thing it's very to where you
know people are looking for signals and
then it matters for follow-on rounds you
can create this halo around your company
this excitement this hype around your
company that I think can be really
powerful especially gives sort of build
on itself and become a self-fulfilling
prophecy yeah especially given Silicon
Valley is so competitive even for talent
right like you can't just hire engineers
that you want yeah don't underestimate
the importance of what yeah that's in
raising a lot of capital from the right
from the right investors can really help
with that got it great so we'll do a
very small rapid-fire round from some of
the Twitter questions that we've had
from our followers one one twitter
follower Ryan McCarthy wants to know why
did you study history at Yale haha I do
believe that history repeats itself if
you can develop pattern recognition yeah
around you know the way things have
unfolded in the past you can actually
predict the future to a certain extent
it's actually even more true in
investing yeah like knowing history
super important yeah I bet that's right
yeah and so yeah really understanding it
for having a firm grasp of the past I
think gives you a more of an ability to
to understand the present and to you
know lead a great life if you know where
things are headed you know especially if
you want to be an entrepreneur I think
that can be it can actually be really
powerful
yeah well Ferriss bringing local local
commerce Jack so yeah the second
question is why do you think Square cash
went on to become a successful app I
think that it was first of all really
focusing on the experience and nailing
the experience the day before we were
supposed to launch Jack made us delay
launch by two days
mmm-hmm in order to change the color of
the app because he thought the color was
too drab and people were freaking out
about it like and who knows if that you
know ended up actually being the thing
that led to to cash a success but it was
that sort of obsession about the details
of the experience particularly on the
consumer side really being in the
details and in recognizing that all you
have is the experience at the end of the
day like that is all that the customers
know you for in opposition to that is we
recognized that the product isn't just
the product yeah the product is the
network and so particularly after we
moved to the native experience and got
rid of the email client which had a
bunch of friction in it
we we launched a really aggressive
referral program yeah where we were
losing a lot of money and honestly a lot
of us including me sort of wondering
like is this does this really make sense
for squares we're about to go public to
be losing all this money and Brian grass
Cydonia and Jack to his credit just
constant application of force just like
kept going and said we're never gonna
have a shot if we don't have people
using this thing and once we got it off
the ground and really invested that's
when the power to of network effect
started to kick in and once we were off
the ground and made that bat we were
able to do all sorts of things with
monetization so it was it was having
that clarity of vision and focusing on
the experience and recognizing that you
know you need you need a big network
yeah I mean the product isn't just the
software it's also you know for us the
product with fair the product is the
products yeah it's the assortment
correct that's it you know I know it's
not that obvious with square cache for
the network angle because venmo has a
strong network right yeah and so what do
you think mate square cache still pulled
that off different network we we we we
tapped into just a different network it
it was it felt like vinne mo was
everywhere because all of our friends
used been Mel yeah and that freaked
people out but VIN mo was only tapping
into like the 1% of the population that
went to Ivy League schools and we're
fresh out of college because it started
at Penn and so it just like dominated it
spread really rapidly in that kind of
millennial yuppies yeah and then cash is
everywhere else and is now I think on
pace to be bigger than men mo because
that that markets actually bigger great
awesome well thank you so much max thank
you for your time
thank you
you